DOING YOUR PART FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THINGS ARE GOING TO CHANGE IF
THIS CONTINUES, YOU CAN BELIEVE
THAT.
THE AUTHOR OF "WOKE INC." AND A
VERY SMART MAN, HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
YOUR PARENTS CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY FROM ANOTHER COUNTRY,
ONE OF THE THINGS IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES HAVE THAT NATIVE-BORN
AMERICANS DON'T IS AN
APPRECIATION OF THE FRAGILITY OF
ECONOMIES.
THEY DON'T IMAGINE THAT EVERYONE
IS GOING TO BE RICH FOR ALL TIME
JUST BECAUSE THEY WERE BORN IN A
RICH COUNTRY, AND WATCHING THESE
PEOPLE TALK, YOU REALLY FEEL
LIKE THAT IS WHAT THEY BELIEVE,
THIS CAN KIND OF GO ON FOREVER,
KEEP PRINTING THE MONEY,
EVERYONE HAS MORE THAN ENOUGH,
MORE DRAG TIME STORY HOURS.
>> EXACTLY, TUCKER.
FIRST OF ALL, TALK ABOUT BEING
WOKE, IT IS THE ULTIMATE
PRIVILEGE, THE REASON YOU DO NOT
SEE WOKENESS INFECTING POOR
COUNTRIES, THEY HAVE BIGGER
THINGS TO WORRY ABOUT THE PEOPLE
PUTTING FOOD ON THE TABLE, THIS
IS THE ULTIMATE PRIVILEGE.
NOW THE UNITED STATES GOES FROM
BEING WELL-OFF TO BEING LESS
WELL OFF AND ALL THE WAYS YOU
LAID OUT, INFLATION, SUPPLY
CHAIN SHORTAGES, WATCHING
FOREIGN POLICY DISASTERS ABROAD,
THE PEOPLE IN POWER, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION USING AND
PROJECTING THESE PROGRESSIVE
VALUES AS A SMOKE SCREEN TO
DEFLECT ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THEIR
ACTUAL POLICY FAILURES, SO YOU
MARK MY WORDS, TUCKER, THE MORE
INFLATION WE SEE, THE MORE
SUPPLY CHAIN SHORTAGES WE SEE
FROM IN A MORE FOREIGN POLICY
DISASTERS WE SEE, THE MORE
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TALKING ABOUT
RACISM OR MISOGYNY OR BIGOTRY OR
WHATEVER AS A WAY OF CHANGING
THE SUBJECT.
TUCKER, YOU SAW IT IN
AFGHANISTAN, FOR EXAMPLE,
THE TALIBAN COMING TO
POWER, ACTUAL TERRACE COMING TO
POWER IN A PLACE WE LEFT A
COUPLE MONTHS AGO BUT THE THING
WE ARE ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT
WITH MERRICK GARLAND'S DOMESTIC
TERRORISM IN THE FORM OF PARENTS
ACTUALLY PUTTING UP PROTESTS TO
THE WAY THEIR KIDS ARE BEING
TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS, CLASSIC
EXAMPLE OF CHANGING THE SUBJECT,
AND MARK MY WORDS, YOU ARE GOING
TO SEE MORE OF IT.
>> Tucker: YOU BLAME THE
RECORDS FOR THE FAILURE OF THE
POTATO HARVEST.
WHITE SUPREMACIST, NO ONE HAS
EVER SEEN ONE, BUT THEY ARE
EVERYWHERE.
I THINK THAT IS A PRETTY HARD
CASE TO MAKE, THOUGH IN THE FACE
OF INCREASING POVERTY.
CAN YOU ACTUALLY CONVINCE PEOPLE
THEY ARE GETTING POORER BECAUSE
QANON IS BAD?
>> YOU HAVE THIS BATTLE ON THE
LEFT, TUCKER, NOT A LOT OF
PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT APPRECIATE
THIS DISTINCTION.
THE OCCUPY WALL STREET LEFT
MOSTLY LEFT IN THE STANDS FOR
TEN YEARS, THEN YOU HAVE THE NEW
WOKE LEFT THAT HAS ACTUALLY HELD
THE REINS OVER POWER.
AS YOU BEGIN TO SEE ECONOMIC
RECESSION AND ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS COUNTRY AND
YOU BEGIN TO SEE INFLATION --
GAS PRICES GO UP, I THINK YOU
ARE GOING TO SEE THE RISE OF THE
OCCUPY WALL STREET LEFT COME
BACK, AND WE ARE ON THE LEFT
NEED TO GO BACK TO ARGUING ABOUT
ECONOMIC INEQUALITY AS A FAULT
TO TALKING ABOUT RACISM AND
MISOGYNY AND BIGOTRY.
I THINK IT'S GREAT TO BE A GOOD
THING FOR THE LEFT AND THIS
COUNTRY BECAUSE THAT IS
ULTIMATELY WHAT THE LEFT AND
RIGHT OUGHT TO BE ARGUING ABOUT.
THEY HAVE DIFFERENT VIEWS ON
REDISTRIBUTION OR TAXATION
POLICY OR THE RIGHT ECONOMIC
POLICIES, BUT WE NEED TO BE
TALKING ABOUT OUR RELIANCE ON
CHINA, NOT A LEFT-WING OR
RIGHT-WING ISSUE.
BOTH PARTIES GUILTY OVER THE
LAST 30 YEARS.
GETTING US BACK ON TOPIC AND
TALKING ABOUT THE THINGS WE NEED
TO BE TALKING BUT AS OPPOSED TO
THE WOKE SMOKE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND THEIR
CORPORATE CRONIES BLOW EVERY DAY
TO CHANGE THE SUBJECT.
>> Tucker: I COULDN'T AGREE
MORE.
THIS IS A GRE